if you are a student of self-defense the
question I'm going to ask you should be
easy to answer
the question is simple
what would you do if someone wanted to
harm you and you couldn't fight them and
you can't run away
lots of people say they study martial
arts for self-defense and they choose
their system based on how much it would
help them in a real situation
if your system is about self-defense it
should be helping you to answer this
question but does it
this video will help you wrap your head
around how and why this question is so
difficult for martial arts systems to
answer and more so it will start to give
you answers to this question
so if you'd like answers to this
question keep listening many martial
arts systems claim to be good for
self-defense but very few of the popular
systems today offer anything outside of
fighting or hope
the problem is that none of the most
popular systems can see beyond fighting
or fantasy and the truth is neither of
these areas is really good for
self-defense
on one side we have what is now known as
Combat Sports
these are systems designed to help teach
you how to fight and for the most part
they do a very good job of doing that
within their limited scope
because of the sporting aspect of these
systems they will constantly pressure
test you and train you to effectively
use the techniques prescribed by the
system inside a physical confrontation
for example
if you study kickboxing you will learn
how to hit hard and how to take hard
shots yourself
you will condition your body to take and
deal abuse for long periods of time
this is great if you're in a one-on-one
striking match but what if someone takes
you to the ground
the obvious answer to this question is
to study a grappling system grappling
sports like Brazilian Jiu Jitsu can give
you a great amount of skill in the area
of ground grappling
and in today's world you could also
study and compete in mixed martial arts
which will give you a well-rounded
approach to Stand-Up striking and
grappling seamlessly merging the two
into one system
but what if they have a weapon
there's multiple attackers they outweigh
You by a few hundred pounds or perhaps
they're just better at MMA than you
it's tempting to say well then you just
run away but running away might not be
that easy they could be faster than you
they could corner you or they could take
you by surprise then what
these kinds of situations are exactly
what self-defense should be preparing
you for however most popular systems
today only talk about situations where
it's possible or ideal to fight the
other person
what if you can't fight them
on the other side of popular martial
arts today we have martial arts that
deal mostly in fantasy the objective of
these martial arts is to create an
aesthetic
because people conflate the idea of
martial arts and self-defense they
automatically think that this aesthetic
is something they can achieve in real
conflict when their life is on the line
they expect to do all kinds of spinning
moves and fancy things to save
themselves and if you've never been in
genuine physical conflict maybe you
think these kinds of things will happen
and it doesn't matter if you're small
because these fancy moves will help you
overcome people much bigger and more
powerful than you
in truth in real physical conflict size
speed violence and aggression absolutely
matter and can never be taken away even
by the fanciest of spinning kicks
as a person who studied martial arts to
achieve an aesthetic and martial arts
based on sport the sport martial arts
tend to be much more practical meaning
that what you do in sport will often
closely resemble what happens in an
actual fight
the problem with sport martial arts is
that they always confine us to people
that we actually can fight this is why
sport martial arts have weight classes
and skill divisions this ensures that
you'll be dealing with someone that you
actually have the ability to fight
if sport martial arts didn't have these
divisions All Sport training would be
limited to supremely physical people who
were very skilled
this would quickly make it impossible
for most of us to learn sport martial
arts
the divisions found in sport martial
arts are all well and good as long as
we're talking about sport but once we
expect sport martial arts to teach us
about self-defense we'll realize that
unless we are one of the gifted few we
may be facing someone who is much bigger
and more skilled than we are how do we
deal with these people of course the
answer is not to fight them
if you get into a fight with an MMA
champ you're likely going to lose so
what can you do
when I began teaching I had studied
martial arts for a long time I was right
around 200 pounds in great physical
shape and in my 30s the problem was I
was often being asked to teach people
who were much smaller than me and less
skilled than me how to defend themselves
so as a teacher how was I going to teach
these people to deal with people who
were physically much greater than them
at first the answer may seem simple well
train them to be as capable and skilled
as you are and they'll be fine but many
of my students were already past the
prime of their life and many of them
would never be the same size I was no
matter how hard they trained and a great
number of them didn't have the time to
become as skilled as I had so how could
I help these students I guess I could
have Shrugged my shoulders and said
sorry you're not cut out to be able to
defend yourself but that didn't sit
right with me I wanted to know if I
could actually train these people to
deal with someone much larger than them
so I began looking at other places for
these answers
then I realized something very important
fighting is always difficult and risky
and ideal self-defense wouldn't involve
fighting at all
in fact the word fight was the wrong
word for what I was now interested in
but as a martial artist fight was the
only word I could conceive of to get it
what I was looking for
the word fight defines so much of what
we do as martial artists that we really
can't see beyond it and that's very
dangerous for someone who's truly
interested in self-defense
I needed a new way to think about the
kinds of skills I wanted outside of
fighting
eventually I realized that everything I
wanted to know was included in the word
conflict
while conflict includes fighting it also
allowed for skills outside of fighting I
eventually came to understand that there
were many more skills to conflict other
than fighting skills and that this new
way of thinking allowed many new skills
that were equal to or even greater than
the skills I had found in fighting
systems
in order to wrap my head around
everything outside of fighting that I
needed to understand I began learning
about what are called conflict
resolution systems and I also created a
chart to help me understand what kinds
of skills were needed I call this chart
the spectrum of conflict
the spectrum of conflict is a simple
chart that is broken into six stages
these six stages are the ones that I
believe to be most important in conflict
the chart is read from left to right it
shows how conflict begins and ends
each stage of the spectrum offers skill
sets that can be used to resolve
conflict
however if you fail to resolve Conflict
at any particular stage you will be
forced to move to the right and attempt
to solve the conflict with those skill
sets as you go further to the right the
chart and stages require more
physicality more skill more effort and
are much more risky if you look at this
chart you can see that fighting skills
are actually the ones that require the
most physicality and are the most risky
and demanding
this is not ideal for self-defense
another interesting thing you can learn
from this chart is how many skills are
not fighting skills in fact only one
third of this chart is devoted to
fighting skills a full two-thirds of
this chart are skills that are
non-fighting skills and can be developed
by anyone regardless of physicality or
age
this chart represents what I needed to
answer my students questions about
self-defense and in the end was what I
wanted to know in order to protect
myself
in the next video I will go into more
detail about the Spectrum and explain
exactly how it works and what it offers
there are many important skills outside
of fighting and is a student of
self-defense you must be able to
understand these skills and how to apply
them
while it's undeniable that fighting
skills are important for self-defense if
you master the skills before fighting
you may never have to fight in your
entire lifetime
and that's truly a wonderful thing
because while it's fun to fight in sport
fighting for your life is something
you'll probably never want to do
if you're interested in the other parts
of this video series you'll have to join
my patreon these videos and other videos
dealing with conflict outside of
fighting will be available on my patreon
Christopher Hein patreon.com thanks for
watching see you in another video soon